on Silence of the Lambs is it true that
did you never speak to Anthony Hopkins
no never spoke to him he was scary the
first day we had a reading me like a
little read through and we I got there
early and then I went to the bathroom
and I came back everybody was sing down
we did the read-through the of the film
and by the end of it I never wanted to
talk to him again I was and so then we
did the whole movie he was always behind
those the glass partitions or he was in
his cell and because the scenes were so
long they'd kind of lock him in at the
beginning of the day and he'd go there
and then the next day he'd be on the
other side and I'd be and I'd be on this
side and we got to the end of the movie
and it really had never had a
conversation but no you never paused
backstage in a car I avoided him I
really avoided him and then I was eating
a tuna fish sandwich it was the last day
and he came up to me and he says he was
sidled up to me and I said I I don't
know I sort of had a tear my I was like
I'm I was really scared of you and he
said I was scared of you
why would anyone be scared of me yes so
when you were filming the scene I'm
available
filming the scenes when he was behind
the partition when they were reset
cameras she just sat there well yeah
because they were he was screwed in you
couldn't I couldn't get to him he was
behind the glass he's staring you right
a lot of the scenes actually in South of
the lambs are done to the camera which
is this sort of odd technique that
Jonathan and Tammy came up with a sort
of Hitchcockian technique and most of
the time that when he's delivering his
lines he's not looking at me he's
looking directly at the camera and I'm
somewhere behind there where he can't
see me
I remember they are you loser this is
such a low point you [ __ ] loser you
know like that and then I will his belly
went in my mouth